[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the observer's
chief leader writer sonia soda and the
telegraph's associate editor for
politics christopher hope both with us
from now until just before midnight so
front pages
let's start with the metro remarking on
burning hot britain and the fires caused
by the record temperatures
according to the mirror ii britain is
burning
another variation on that theme in the
telegraph which says britain ignites as
temperatures break 40 degrees celsius
barrier for the first time
the eye calls the conditions a tinderbox
the guardian describes them as a wake-up
call
while the star suggests the heat has
turned people into a nation of zombies
in other news the conservative
leadership candidate liz tross has given
an interview to the express in which she
sets
out her case to be prime minister
while the daily mail says her allies
have warned wishy sunak not to do what
it calls dirty backroom deals to try to
get into downing street
according to the financial times the
governor of the bank of england andrew
bailey has indicated he may increase
interest rates by half a point early
next month with the aim of tackling
rising prices
well a reminder by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us so
let's go to our guest then uh sonia soda
and christopher hope you are here with
me now um and christopher what a day and
you know extraordinary pictures which we
see on on the front pages not
surprisingly
just extraordinary and so hot i mean
i've been stuck at home because i had no
trains in london for north london today
so i've been stuck at home here wearing
my summery shirt but i mean it has been
extraordinary weather um and and quite
apocalyptic i think we had some some
rain just just come in here in
hartfordshire in the past 20 minutes so
just tearing it down i mean it does feel
like we are
going through climate change the literal
meaning of that word
absolutely and we saw the pictures of
places like wellington in greater london
uh dartford also in kent also fires in
leicestershire norfolk i mean you name
it across the country it was it was it
was almost like a spontaneous combustion
wasn't it sonya
well i think christopher used the right
words when he used the word apocalyptic
um and it's really really worrying
obviously when temperatures are this
high it's much easier for fires to
happen
um it's really significant in terms of
the roads we've seen tarmac melting
we've seen whole rail lines closed
because it just wasn't safe to run the
trains in these temperatures so it
really does sort of bring the country to
a halt and it's a very very concerning
sign
of what is now already uh sort of upon
us in terms of the climate crisis and i
think it's a very very grave reminder
of the fact that you know we need to be
taking urgent action as a globe really
urgent international action because the
problem with the climate crisis is that
there's a tipping point and when it goes
beyond a certain point actually there's
not going to be very much that we can do
to slow it down so it's very very
important that we act now that net zero
target is so critical uh to sort of um
minimizing these these sorts of uh
events
and there is the uh the eye tinderbox uk
ignites at a record 40.3 degrees um they
say at least 34 weather stations in
england exceeded the previous uk
temperature record and scientists warn
public to expect frequent extreme
weather because of climate change to be
fair they've been doing that for years
if not decades christopher but right now
as we see the energy crisis has subsumed
the climate crisis so where do we go
from here
well that's right we have to recalibrate
i think how we protect ourselves against
major weather events the problem is this
country is not not ready nor it's it's
infrastructure is equipped for this kind
of heat you see there those those houses
burning i think there must be in in
north london there great london um the
homes built by the victorians that many
of us live in were not built for this
kind of heat so we needed better
installation on them to try and keep out
the heat as well as keep in the heat in
winter time
and the infrastructure doesn't work i
heard that grant shap saying today the
transport secretary but our railway
tracks can't really work above 35
degrees centigrade when it's 40 degrees
centigrade well of course they're gonna
start warping and that's why there are
no trains today for me and so people are
going to have this i think it's a real a
real um reminder them you forget
extension rebellion and the protesters
who who shut down or try to attack
news uk today well more interestingly i
think is the fact that the weather is
gonna
educate educate so many of us now about
climate change
yes i did here in fact that uh the much
criticized hs2 will have its rails um uh
locked in with concrete so
they can't buckle so perhaps that's
technology in action uh but the metro
there with uh with the house ablaze you
know as you said our infrastructure is
not prepared for this nor is our housing
that's being built either you know
there's a great focus on insulation not
necessarily about dealing with these
extremes of weather the mirror ii
britain's burning 40 degrees centigrade
wildfires sweep the uk in record heat
and do you think the fact that there
were fires you know took people away
from the the sort of the lido pictures
of everyone enjoying the hot sunshine
and and made people realize how serious
and dangerous this actually was sonja
i think so i think there's that and i
think also there's a fact that we've
seen such serious disruption but also i
mean it's just too hot to go to the lido
and enjoy the hot weather i'm normally
somebody who really enjoys the sunshine
enjoys getting out and about but even i
just saw it was just it was just i mean
well actually we can see some people
enjoying it there but it was just it's
just too hot to be out and about and you
know as we've all been saying our
infrastructure really isn't designed for
this and i think it is just an
incredibly serious um wake-up call so um
but but who would have thought i mean i
mean as you say anna scientists have
been warning us about this for a number
of years now and i think scientific
understanding has really increased over
the last 20 years about the rapidity
with which the climate crisis is
happening and global overheating um is
happening but it is extraordinary isn't
it because we see news stories about
sort of wildfires in you know other
countries um around the world in places
like australia and california and to see
fires in the uk that have been sort of
triggered you know grass fires by high
temperatures
it is just kind of quite extraordinary
really and certainly yesterday we were
told we need to rethink of ourselves as
a you know cold climber or a tempered
humid human climate as we are you know
we're we're now a warmer nation and the
guardian you know
spells out some of the consequences of
that not least the major incidents which
we saw in greater london and elsewhere
briefly leicestershire as well in terms
of fire although they rescinded that
tonight um households in southeast
england told to save water by switching
off washing machines farmers said the
drought was hitting animal feed supplies
experts calculating close to a thousand
people were likely to die as a result of
the hot spell from sunday to wednesday
um and so it goes on christopher
yeah but it's raining tonight in
harbinger i mean you know it's called
the weather i mean i think we need to be
slightly you know let's damp it down a
bit now it's hot even wherever we are
now tonight um we don't know what caused
these um these fires on these grasslands
maybe it was a stray cigarette a stray
match maybe someone lit a bonfire madly
maybe there's a bit of education for
people how about how to behave in hot
weather um maybe maybe we shouldn't to
get get get too too panicked about it
certainly the issue of excess deaths is
the most i think telling thing there's
always excess deaths whenever you have
extreme weather whether it's whether
it's hot or whether it's cold and that's
really sad it's it's not not been not to
be uh i think it's a degree of education
here i think for people to dem to how to
work with the new world which is one of
climate change well scientists have said
tonight that there is no way the uk
could get to 40 degrees without climate
change
and the reason
that you see forest fires like this is
because there's been precious little
rain in the southeast at least for for
for many a month so you know you can't
underplay temperatures that we never
thought we would see i mean a hot summer
in the uk in england would be about 26
degrees normally wouldn't it
yeah absolutely no i think that's
absolutely right and i think you know
what we will be seeing more of
um unless we can get to net zero very
very quickly is that this situation is
going to get worse and scientists are
predicting that we're going to be start
seeing these temperatures first of all
once every three years and then even
more frequently than that so um you know
it it is absolutely a wake-up call it
has been it's been by climate change and
um you know we need
things are going to get worse unless we
take action with other countries to do
something about it and yes you can try
and adapt as best you can but
unfortunately um you know there are
countries around the world where
adaptation just doesn't work and
habitable environments simply won't
exist anymore i know we'll look ahead to
the uh the final round of the
conservative contest in just a moment
but just on net zero and the views of
one or other of them who's going to be
our next prime minister kemi badenock
finally coming out suggesting that she
does support net zero but a narrative
around some of the campaigns that
actually any net zero efforts in this
country should not hinder economic
growth now if if that is the case is
that sustainable
is it possible christopher and how much
will this as an issue come back onto the
table do you think
well there's clearly a tension isn't
there between cost of living crisis all
the other drains on on government
resource and and this this target
pushed into law by theresa may in the
last few weeks of her being prime
minister to net zero by 2050 kemi
bedlock had quite an interesting and i
think quite a nuanced position which i
think the other candidates might adopt
is
okay that's a good target to go for but
none of us in power now are going to be
on the hook that number will be retired
by then so you say let's work out why we
aim for that number by that date but
that's certainly what i think you might
find some of the the the two candidates
when they emerge tomorrow afternoon
short-term
that's in a minute i think net zero you
know i think yes it's important and
sonia's right to say it's important but
equally people have to be able to heat
themselves and and live and have a life
between now and 2050 when they can't
overwhelm people with bills and extra
costs from all the all the green levees
put on their bill yes i think kemi
badenock suggested 2050 was an arbitrary
date apologies uh sonia um but it was
one that the world worked you for cop
wasn't it anyway sonia do you apologize
well i i just think there's a bit of a
false dichotomy going on here about you
know economic growth in the long term
and averting climate catastrophe in the
long term it's sort of the same
situation as we had in the pandemic
where everyone was where some people
like cenac were saying well we can't
lock down it's bad for the economy well
actually if you don't take action in the
here and now when you need it it's going
to be terrible for the economy in the
long term and actually there's quite a
lot of research i think that links
planning for the long term
investing in green technology for
example um that that can be linked to
economic growth so i think it's a false
dichotomy to say it's either economic
growth or we save ourselves from
catastrophic climate change i think
actually the latter is really critical
if we want to sort of have economic
growth over a sort of 50-year time
window
i'll leave i'll leave your sigh there i
think probably shall we we will move on
to the other critical uh time frame
anyway which is the conservative
leadership
elections could liz trust
be poised for a come from behind victory
in that tour leadership contest
discussing that in detail after this
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview joining me once again
sonia soda and christopher hope um
christo i'm going to go to you again for
obviously reasons apologies sonja but
we're going to talk about liz trust
who's making the front pages of both the
daily mail and the daily express the the
male
trust allies won no dirty back room deal
deals as serge makes liz the bookies
favorite to be prime minister
and the daily express um has promised
hard-pressed britons she will tackle the
crippling cost of living crisis as she
sees the momentum in the race to number
10. both papers clearly supporting her i
don't know what your paper is supporting
uh necessarily maybe you can tell us but
what do you make about um you know the
front page of the mail for example um
these allegations of dirty back room
deals skullduggery and lending of votes
etc
well that's exactly what everyone's
telling me is happening and everyone is
saying to us that they were surprised by
the fact that ricky tsunac only advanced
by three in the in the the uh fourth
round of voting this afternoon and many
think the votes were lent by some of the
people working with the rich sunnah
campaign to lose trust to try and force
out penny mordont uh trust is now um
around 10 or so or less than that i
think the
memory she's quite near to penny
mordaunt the view from the bookies and
tory mps that that so this trust will
overtake penny mordor tomorrow in the
final and fifth round of voting and then
it'll be trust versus sunak to go to the
the members of the members of the party
next month but certainly the feeling
behind this trust she's a she is the
candidate
i think intellectually that's the that's
the debate which uh richie sunak wants
to ha about low tax versus high tax
which is where he sits
i think with penny mordaunt that might
be the candidate who he fears more
because she's so popular with the bass
and he can't really answer her kind of
connections that she would have with the
membership i think that's the problem
he's got he prefers trust not mordor
well she was but she certainly feels
like she's been nobbled doesn't she um
in certain elements of the media and
elsewhere um your paper uh suggests that
liz trust has moved into prime position
to reach the final two um inside uh the
metro as well um you know bad knock not
good enough you know suggestions of
cabinet roles and uh the telegraph
suggesting that miss truss has hinted at
possible cabinet jobs for newer tory mps
like mrs bednar because she promises a
government of all the talents that's
certainly a way of attracting voters and
support how do you see this shaping up
sonia and is there any mathematical
possibility that rishi sunat will not be
in the final two
i think it looks unlikely because he's
actually now um you know when you when
you consider that one mp has been uh
knocked out because uh tobias elwood
because he lost the the whip today uh
rishi sooner actually only needs 119 now
i think to go through and he's on 118 so
i think it's very unlikely that he's not
going to be one of the two on the ballot
i think it's it's quite tricky to you
know party memberships are notoriously
difficult to poll accurately and
actually things have been quite
changeable if you look at for example
the yougov polls of conservative party
members over the last two or three weeks
or so we really saw penny um morgan kind
of pull ahead um but actually in the
latest poll to come out it looks like
it's all quite close but rishi sunap
looks like he would lose to both morden
and trust in a runoff with the two of
them but that actually he might do a bit
better against morden so i think it's
it's very difficult sometimes to call
exactly how party memberships are going
to vote but i i agree with christopher
that i think that what's most likely to
happen the most likely outcome is a
sunac versus um trust runoff now and i
think you know there may have been some
games sort of it may have been some
strategizing by this soon at camp but
also
if you look at you know who who's who's
been knocked out you can see how some of
those you know in the next person uh to
be the person to be knocked out today
can we
it feels quite likely that that quite a
few of her votes might go to trust yes
and in fact the times there the right
will back me says the foreign secretary
we could talk all night about that
couldn't we thank you so much both of
you